c'était de marée compact et d'habillage
en grève
que
et 3 2
vous êtes qui vous ton frangin
ça m'a pris 28 ans mais je n'ai retrouvé
oh mon dieu s'était pas occupé j'espère
si tout prix ma présence est top
secrètes nous lèvres en resteront fermés
elle parle de son déjà fait le site
assure le bébé arrive quand super
enceinte juste grosses gouttes été
pendant toutes ces années je suis agent
secret je travaille pour le mi6
s'inquiète pas et les blindés
on sent rien et où la bagnole à les
vitres blindées remonte la vitrine à
sept milliards d'êtres humains sur une
planète qui ne pas en contenir que si
des gens vont mourir si on n'arrête pas
je laisserai pas tout seul sur ce coup
là on y va
hier j'avais une vie normale pépère
aujourd'hui on se bat pour sauver le
monde
c'est mon frère il a besoin de moi tu es
ces crétins
cette flèche est contient une toxine si
je veux m'en sortir il faut qu'une juge
absolument hors de question j'ai la vie
brisée t'inquiète je suis là laisse
l'espionnage at-on franches ou nude
tiens
ta vie tu doit séduire la gent en robe
verte ne peut pas la rater elle est
canon non elle est ultra canon je vous
fais le ménage du show le plafond